[Music]
good afternoon I am cotton 11 dove ski
and today I will present the solution
for masking medical form asking personal
data in medical documents so enjoy at
first few words about me I am the big
writer developer and natural language
processing specialist and I work for the
Raj company and this is the
pharmaceutical company and I work in the
global IT solution Center which supports
the core business which is pharmacy from
the site of of the IT
okay so outline of today's presentation
is is quite short it's only three points
the first one is a business
justification of of the project the
second one is the architectural high of
a literature overview and the last one
is devoted to the implementation and
this one will be the longest ok so
business case pharmacy is very very
crazy business and we have a lot of
external and internal policies regarding
to sharing data to showing data even
inside the company not on the outside of
them and all the data containing
personal information has to be the
intensified what does it mean it means
that they have to be masked all the
personal data have to be removed or
replaced by some placeholders or
something like that yeah and some
regulatories force the pharmaceutical
company to do this with all of this of
the data and this process cannot be
performed manually because the number of
the documents is pretty high and growing
so we had to implement some so
automatically solution for for solving
this task ok in our case the first our
internal client let's say was the
medical information part of the company
the medical information is a part of
each pharmaceutical company have you
ever heard about this anyone
now okay so medical information is a
part which is responsible for supporting
all the projects available on the market
and they have to response all the
questions related to to the products to
the dosages of medicines to the clinical
trials results etc and they receives a
lot of communications from from
scientists from physicians from medical
doctors from even patients with
questions about some dosages adverse
events etc I and all these questions has
to be respond by by the medical
information part and they are doing this
this job very well but for a little bit
more advanced analytic doing all this
data they have to they have to mask all
the personal data of these documents
because they are not the data scientist
and the batches with with all this
question all those inquiries could be
really really helpful and proceed some
some nice insights from this data and
for sharing the data with the other
teams with the external companies or
just external tools outside our our
intranet the data has to be masked and
this was our first this was our first
implementation we had to do and this is
the definition of medical inquiry and
example of medical inquiry they received
so as you see it is a lot of personal
data on each document this one is quite
short but a lot of them are bit longer
but it's don't fit on the slide so is
this one yeah and as you see this is the
person named address email address the
phone number and all of them has to be
has to be masked
and from there we we go to to our
architecture the one of our
architectural constraints was to
integrate this solution
for masking their personal data with
existing tool for analytics for medical
information text for Isis is also the
tool they are able to use for do some
simple analysis like just hottest topic
detection and most frequent words at
extra etc yeah and we had to integrate
our solution for masking with them and
the solution existing was established as
a Hadoop project with usage of MapReduce
paradigm and HDFS data storage and also
a cool data storage so we had to we had
to build the solution which is an
additional step between retrieving the
data and and passing them to the
analytics tool and our data masking
solution does not impact on the context
of the words in the sentences when they
are masked they are still the same part
of speech so so they can be analyzed by
the NLP tools as well as without without
this masking yeah and this is something
that that indicates that we have to use
some solution which is related with the
Hadoop ecosystem with one produced
paradigm and we decided to use the
Hadoop streaming Hadoop streaming is a
pretty powerful tool which allow us to
to run the code written in any language
any programming language as a MapReduce
task and here we use this for write in
for write write code in Python to use
the Hadoop streaming your code has to
have much free requirements the first
one is you cluster has to support the
the programming language you you choose
so this is why we choose the Python to
not Python free because our caldera
instruction instruction doesn't support
inter Python free for now yeah and the
other two requirements is you have to
communicate between the workers between
mappers resource data source via
standard input and output and the third
requirement is all the sensor data has
to be a key value data and in our in our
case what you can see on the slide it is
the CSV data when the first column is
just the identifier and the other
columns as to that just as a volume from
this key valio key value give all the
approach okay so this is a pipeline of
our single mapper our single mapper
which is which is dedicated for
processing one document at once is
retrieving the data from from HDFS which
are previously copied from Oracle
database and in the first step of each
mapper we try to detect the language of
the document because all of the
component components we use in the
fartole processing are pretty language
dependent yeah so the first step is to
to detect the language and we also have
information about the country from the
inquiry comes because this is also very
important information for for us
languages come also country because we
support for example to Switzerland where
we have three different languages which
are used by by citizens ok and after
after detecting the language we go to
the to the next step the next step is
the finding step we have a lot of
specialized finders which are
responsible for finding just one kind of
entity with usage of just one method and
today work independently so we have five
or six of for finding some entities and
yeah and each entity is founded by
another finders so we have I don't know
20 or 40 independent evil king finders
and they are trying to to find some
entities to be masked in completely
different ways
then thereafter this finder's has to be
merged because some of entities can be
overlapping or pretty design and this
this way is pretty pretty good in
increasing recall of our finders because
we we find a lot of false positives but
also a lot and pretty much pretty all
the the false positives so this was our
our yeah this was the most important for
us to to increasingly recall as high as
it is possible with some yeah without
worrying about the precision because we
have additional step which we call
filters and in this face we remove some
some false positives okay answer after
this step we mask the data and store
them into the reporting database which
is a part of the pipeline from the
solution for medical information textual
analytics okay so first type of finder
we have is pretty simple we use the
regular expressions which is pretty fast
pretty pretty good it has very very well
results for well formatted well
structured data like email addresses
phone numbers postal codes etc and I
think the most if you use the regular
expressions so I have a question for you
how do what do you think about the
regular expression for finding limits
how long it could be given number of
characters mm and ideas sorry
couple of lines okay this is our regular
expression for finding just you mics it
is pretty complicated but the easiest
easiest version simple simplest versions
were not able to find all of the emails
you have because users are really
creative in in registering you image
account and in the real real data this
is the only this is the simplest regular
expressions we were able to use in our
in our data to have one 100% recall for
fighting image yeah so over 400
characters and 11 groups yeah okay so we
also use this for finding phone numbers
and postal codes this situation is
simpler the regular expression are
simpler simpler but but this is
additional problem in each country we
support the phone numbers and postal
codes has completely different formats
for postal code it is completely obvious
but I was very very shocked when I tried
to use the regular expressions for
finding English phone numbers in the
German data and in the other languages
because the even length of the phone
numbers is is pretty different in in a
lot of European countries so we have the
9 digits numbers in Germany really often
they are 10 or 11 tickets even so it was
it was pretty challenging to to create
regular expressions for each country and
I already does if I summarize the length
of all of them it will be longer than
the regular expression for us okay the
next approach we we took is the approach
based on the dictionaries as a big
pharmaceutical company we have a lot of
dictionaries containing the names of
hospitals the names of our competitors
the world the names of the companies we
are co-working constantly
so we decided to use them and it was
pretty it was pretty good idea because
it's increase our recall significantly
but we also had a few problems with that
the first one is what's the performance
merging matching the dictionaries
containing a few millions of Records
with our text was pretty slow so ever
for us for a single document we had to
perform over over half of billion
matches and we decided to reorganize our
dictionaries and to use the a holistic
algorithm for increase the speed of of
finding entities and it was a pretty
good idea because it is much much faster
but unfortunately it requires a lot of
memory and a lot of time to build and
these structures called the tree or the
suffix tree this it's not a type of this
is the name of the structure used in
this algorithm yeah so we decided to we
decided to use these methods and this
has also one more limitation it supports
only the exact matches so if we have
some inflected forms of any words it it
doesn't work generally but in case of
the personal information in in case of
company names company addresses they are
also in the very simple for this is
singular for each European language etc
so we we don't worry about this
situation the the most challenging
situation was with some abbreviations
and shortcuts because we had to unify
all our dictionaries and we had to add a
normalization step for the commune's
processing to have always the same form
for this type of for this type of
for entities because st john's it should
be completely the same as st. John and
cetera so we had to ask some native
speakers some linguists to generate the
rules for replacing all these
abbreviation and so on into their full
forms and then we were able to use use
them as but it significantly increased
the pickle and even precision of our
solutions so it is it was really really
world 'fl to to implement this this
approach and this is how this suffix
tree looks like okay the most
sophisticated approach we used in this
solution is the named entities
recognizer now this is the sub task from
natural language processing which is
responsible for using an in statistical
model or something like that an emotion
learning model to locate and recognize
the entities which can be the person
names locations names addresses or time
events or something like that
so this is the pretty thing we we needed
but the implementations of now notice
were not were not sufficient for us and
this is only one of additional finder we
used not the only one because the models
are not well trained on the data we have
they are usually trained on the
corporal's conda corpora from for
example newspapers etc and this is
pretty pretty different things that the
emails but still it is usable and so you
can increase the overall quality of the
solution yeah we decided to use the
stand partner this is how it work on on
this inquiry I showed previously it is
able to find
three types of the model we use for
English is able to find three types of
entities the person name location name
and organization name and here we have
some some false positives and all we
wanted to do we found it is but but we
have some some over fighting some false
positives why we decided to use the
nerve from Stanford University because
they provide the models for the
languages we started to work with so
English German and Spanish unfortunately
they don't support French or Italian but
and we had to train our own models but
we found on the internet some free for
access the corpora are notated by
linguist and we were able to to use them
to train our own models yeah and this is
also pretty challenging because the
corpora annotation format is not always
the same for all the input data and we
had to put a lot of effort to prepare
the format for be for be suitable to our
to our stand Fortner approach yeah and
the training of this models training of
conditional random fields classifier on
big amount of data is is pretty slow and
on this laptop each took over 20 hours
so and I done some mistake before
teaching this model and I had to reply
this this process and it took me over
one week to get the model from well
annotated data yeah so this yeah and so
our solution is written in Python but we
don't use the Python implementation of
this
stan fourtner why because the Python
implementation is is based on an LD K
and there is a big bug in this in this
library related to the named entity
recognition because an LT k reloads
model really often I don't know why and
it is pretty slow because the language
model can have over two gigabytes and
reloading the two gigabytes from the
hardest memory a few times in a minute
is a pretty pretty priest so and we had
to to find another solution
fortunately the one of solutions
proposed by Stanford University is
pretty well working the solution is to
run the java application the java stand
Fortner as a web service and just
communicating from the Python code to
this web service the model is loaded
only once at start and it works pretty
good and pretty fast okay so the the
last kind of finders views is the
rule-based finder after we receive a lot
of corpora annotated by our subject
matter experts and after automatically
masking a lot of documents we decide to
find some rules which are related to the
words order in the in the documents and
we tried to find after which word after
what word the entity we would like to
find occurs really frequent and we
receive some obvious rules like like
there which are pretty pretty common for
our emails but we also retrieve some
some very variable insights and they
impact us to force us to to rewrite some
regular expressions we used to be better
to be to be most suitable to our data
because this analyze was pretty pretty
fruitful for us okay and after after
finding the data after the finders
finish their work we go to the filter
space in the filters face we have we
filtered false positives why we do this
in this face not white unique models
because it is easier if we have the
models which are ready from the Stanford
University or something like that we
don't want to retry them to increase the
precision the recall is satisfying us
and we have some rules for filtering the
data which are false positive for us and
we just drop them in this in this face
yeah here we have the example with free
entities which are recognized as a
person eyes and only the one the one is
the correct person name do you have any
idea why sabrina is is not really close
sabrina is the name of clinical clinical
study yeah so this is yeah but but but
but good good intuition so we we have
also the dictionary of all clinical
studies names etc because they are
really often named as by English female
names and we have to filter in this step
because we are not able to enforce now
to to make to drop these kinds of of
names in the previous stage after
filtering we merge the entities it is
also a pretty interesting thing we do
because if the worker if the finders
work completely independently they can
find the same entities in the same
places or some overlapping entities or
something like that
and sometimes we have the situation that
in this text donor or the other finders
find the bound George Washington as a
person named the second one found the
Washington's potala and we have to apply
the rule for merging these two entities
it is pretty obvious because these two
are overlapping so we can merge them and
the question is what labor we should put
it is the person name the account name
or something like that and we had to
work a few days with our subject matter
expert to prioritize the type of
entities and to create some rules to
decide which entity type is more general
or something like that and which one
should be should be applied and when we
have the data find filtered and merge
the entities we are able to master data
and this step is is pretty simple
because we are just replacing the found
entities by some placeholders for now we
are supporting the five type of entities
person name account name or organization
name post address email address and
phone numbers this fine this five are
required by some external regressions
for pharmaceutical companies so this is
enough for us and yeah and that's it our
future plans we would like to support
some East Asian languages the Chinese is
the next one for now we support seven
languages but each of them are your
European languages yeah and the other
step in the future we would like to to
do is to support the mixed language
documents because we have few documents
which are for example the emails written
in German then forwarded to someone who
is English speaker and the message in
the four words one is in English so we
have
the document in two different languages
and if we recognize this one as a German
the whole document is possessed by
German German pipeline and the data the
dinner or any other language dependence
and the other language dependent finders
are doing a lot of mistakes for the data
written in English in the English part
so we would like to to rewrite it a
little bit to be not the document
oriented by it may be centers oriented
or something like that to proceed this
okay so that's it from my side thank you
for your attention I hope you enjoyed
this presentation thank you very much
and do you have any questions maybe
thank you for interesting presentation
and do you support Polish language and
maybe and - are you planning to provide
service maybe the cloud-based service
for the process that you have presented
company regulations company and the
regulations from the external law are
really restrictive for us and we are not
able to to do is add a service and the
first question of you is if we support
the Polish language now we don't because
we don't have a lot of the documents
written in Polish and even the medical
information units we implemented this
solution for our sometimes translating
all of the communication coming to them
to the to the English and this is this
is the solution for for English and all
for them for example in Greece they
translate of the inquiries from Greece
to to English
how do you resolve conflicts like this
dictionary entry Sabrina and you should
not mask it and this may be a woman
named Sabrina still and you should mask
it so how do you solve these type of
convicts okay so in this situation we
just leave the name because the single
person name is not the personality the
personalized data is if you are able to
recognize the particular people by
getting to Zeta and the single female
name is not because they could be a lot
of Sabrina's in the company so this is
not not not a big deal for us thank you
for the presentation it was very very
good
you were saying
yeah thanks as well very interesting I
have a question about the label said
that you use because we we had a similar
project detecting PII and pH I but from
the security perspective but what we
found out is that these if I so
correctly use like person name and
location and things like these they
didn't really apply very well like
location is maybe Poland but you really
want to mask the street address that's
just the Poland part so what we ended up
doing is we had to create our own labels
and then annotate the data and create
our own entities basically so my
question is was it enough for you these
generic models with the generic label so
did you do the same thing something else
ok the labels we have are requested by
the HIPAA or regulatory so this 5 this 5
type of entities are has to be mask in
all documents in pharmaceutical and
medical companies and these 5 labels are
pretty enough for us because if we would
like to leave some information like the
country of something like that we just
add the additional filter this is this
is the way we we handle it so if we
would like to mask the the street name
or home number or something like that we
do this and if we have the name of
country like Poland Germany or something
we leave it if it is in our dictionaries
if there is no more questions I would
like to invite you for lunch break
you